So week ago. I decided to try to create a computer file video completely from scratch, just using free software
[I] don't mean free software
Where you're giving it bundled with a computer or that you can download for free off [the] internet and then the new Dalish
But I can't even say new definition of free software and the video that I'm trying to make
It's not actually published as I'm [recording] this
Is with Matt lee who's a chap who used to work for the free software foundation?
So he's deaf and what free software is in their eyes
And it's all about freedom of speech as opposed to free as in money
[go] and have a look at that video if you want to know more
But this thing that he said when I was interviewing him struck me, so it was this bit here. [no] video editing isn't always
The easiest thing to do with free software it can be done right people do edit video with free software all the time
And you know video editing software is somewhat in its infancy
As free software he said it videos editing [software's] somewhat in its infancy in free software terms
And I discovered there [were] lots of free applications out [there] to do video editing on not all of them met my needs
And not all [of] them were reliable and not all of them were that easy to install
So the other thing about this video that I'm making now that I'm to try to explain the process I went through
I'm just trying to explain the process. I am not flying a flag for any specific bit of software
I'm not doing a tutorial on how to use those bits of software
Many of you guys out there know a lot more about those sorts of things than I do all I tried to do was say
Right ok, I'm a user. I'm used to editing video. Let's see if I can do it free software, so
[I] was going to actually do this as a blog post
And explain all of the things that had gone through and I thought well no we're computer file. We make computer videos
Let's see if the average user ie me can go out there and do something like video editing for free
So I prefer what I term as the blunt under the camera
Which is a bit without the lens on it, so apologies for me fluffing my way through this
But I did think it'd be worth as just explaining very briefly
How we make or how we shoot a computer file video?
That way you'll understand what I needed to be able to get out of [the] free software
What do we do when we shoot a computer file video? Well? We obviously use a camera sometimes more than one camera
That's why there's another one here for the moment. We obviously need to record the audio of whoever it is
We're interviewing now most cameras will record at least two channels of audio
and
We use one of those with this kind of microphone that you can see here on me. That's a lapel mic
That's the main microphone that we use the other microphone is a microphone on the camera often called the top mic
It's used as backup [the] idea is if something goes wrong with this and we don't notice it
We've at least got that to rely on now
When you come to edit that means?
Ideally you want to throw away the audio off that microphone so first of all we need to be ability to be able to split
Out what's recorded as a stereo track?
into two mono tracks in order to choose which [of] those mono tracks we want people to be able to listen to so that's
One thing is very important the other thing is that the camera that I use is quite [a] high dynamic range
and that means it's able to capture a lot in the low lights that shadows the dark areas what you're seeing here probably and
Quite a lot in the [high] [light] so perhaps
The lights coming down here or the light on the screen when that comes to video
You then need to change the contrast to basically allow video to be able to see all of those things
so if you can see this shot here of
map that I did quite a snatched interview on the steps of the station you can see it was very bright behind him and
Well his face was correctly exposed but then he obviously had a black top on so when I came to edit this
originally I would do something on the contrast to basically make that a bit more palatable and the
Editing software. I'm showing you here is avid media composer. It's one of the industry standards for video editing
This is not free software, but [to] make this project a reality what I decided to do is edit it in my normal way
So that I knew what I was looking for and then go and try and recreate that on a free piece [of] [software] that way
At least I wasn't learning the software and making the creative decisions at the same time so in a moment
I'll show you the free software that I ended up using but I just wanted to explain something of the process so on this
video editing software here
We've got our sauce pictures, and we've got what we're going to do is our edit and then down the bottoms
What's called a timeline people know one [of] those is in this video?
Editing software it splits into V for video tracks and a for audio tracks, and you can see that. It's fairly straightforward
[wherever] there's a change in a block here. It's an edit point
And some things where I floated something over the top and right at the end at the promo section here
you can see quite a lot going on that's because of
Several layers of video going to make that there's each of the four looking sub screens. There's the background
There's the text on top of there
So that's quite a lot of video going on there this windows 7 machine which runs the editing software also Runs
After-effects and various other bits and pieces like photoshop and audio editing for when I need to do that
But is kept completely separate from anything else
It does have a network link to rest on [my] system
But I have this machine here as an admin machine for uploading to the internet for checking emails, ETc, Etc
So what I've ended up doing is the video edit has happened on my admin machine
Which is really really slowed me down in a lot of respects, but this machine here is running ubuntu 1204
But the whole idea of this came about the fact that on top of all of this
I have [a] backup machine that I thought I might be able to rejuvenate this old machine that I just have for backup purposes
Put something on it that might actually work and just be a video editor in the end that went to pot my ended up using
My admin machine because it's a bit more powerful
I'll go through those specs of the machines in a moment that suffice to say that my admin machine used to be
My main machine running avid it's a [quad] [core]
fairly decent machine from a Few years ago with [4] gigs of ram easily able to Handle HD video, so
The other machine the old machine which is on a keyboard and [monitor] and mouse [switch] here
This is where I started this experiment on this machine here
Which is probably going to finish the experiment as [well], and I'll kind of come to that in a moment
I tried to put on open [suzi] twice. I tried to load open [Susi] [onto] it
Installation failed for no apparent reason well obviously there was a reason that it didn't let me know what it was Debian
I thought that would be a good bet, so I put Debian on it
I got the black screen of [death] that I'm calling it a mouse pointer
You could see but nothing else tried installing that three or four times spent a lot of time on Debian
typing things into the command prompt terminal I could get to
Using google to try and find different ways of trying to get graphics drivers to make my system work
We didn't get anywhere with it went for new sense [news] sense
Nuisance
[new] sense
Because it was recommended by the free software foundation. That's what it's running at the moment. It's done quite well [on] that, but I didn't
Just go straight to that. I also tried a diabolic. Which I thought a great potential
That's a fantastic looking thing which I've still got the cD for [cuz] I plan to use or try again
Comes a cinelerra which is a piece of software [which] looked quite promising?
So could only get it to run off the CD. Couldn't get it to run off the hard drive. That's probably my fault
[ok] so you get this splash screen at the top and
Then if you go into sound and video you'll [find] an application called cinelerra, and I believe you can run this on different distros
personal error loads up and
Looks very promising. [I] did have some problems with it though
I couldn't seem to get audio to work and output was a problem
So some of the things we were coming out with was this less than 2 minutes long yet
Nearly 2 gigabytes in size and obviously some kind of problem with the colors there
And this which looked really [promising]
But again mute even outputting an MP3 file was suddenly mute
so what I did think at that point was it's a promising bit of software and
what I decided it was try and run it on one of the more powerful machines the Admin machine or
Even my main wind [surfing] machine because it would have run off the CD
So wouldn't run upon even either my admin machine
which is quite a you know decent machine called 2 quad NVIdia video card or
This which is a z on an intel xeon machine 2.8
[quad-core]
processor so very decent decent spec machines
And that's where I went off to try a bun [2] and then I got to a point where I thought why [am] I bothering?
With the bun 2 on this when I've already got a bun 2 on a more powerful machine
Which is why I ended up making the the video on my admin machine the graphics on computer file?
That's all of this stuff. You can see here was all created in Adobe after effects and photoshop
But I've recreated them for the video that I put out last I recreated them
Gimp [I] know they're not animated
And I probably could have done that if I'd had more time to work in things like Blender. Which is another free piece of software
Unfortunately, I've spent a week on this now and the biggest bottleneck apart from learning the software has been
Finding software that will work most of my machines here have got in fact all of these three machines have got NVIdia video cards in
unfortunately
Nvidia and Linux don't always play that well together there are ways around it you guys know [a] lot more about that
And I do what I don't have time for is spending hours and hours and hours trying to find
The right thing to make it work, so this is probably the whole
point of the exercise in One Nutshell
The guys are over at [Nu] and the free software foundation
And matt who I spoke to are very very keen on the idea of free doesn't just mean how much it costs
but for me the trade-off is between how much time it takes to get it working and
How much it costs as opposed to the freedom of speech thing so I understand the point of freedom speech? I think it's fantastic
I like the idea of it, and I think there's room for both things in this world. So what are you doing gimp? Well?
I created the computer file graphics from scratch very impressed with it [very] close to what I'm used [to] using in things like
Photoshop Perhaps, they don't look quite
exactly the same but
Used gimp to make the thumbnail for the video
Which is this here?
[I] also use gimp to
Make the start plate which is binary background with the computer file logo on it. I was able to do everything
I wanted to do in gimp not quite as quickly and easily in photoshop to deselect something is cTRl + D and in gimp that?
Duplicates it so I did that a few times. I had lots and lots of copies of things running around
All the while was trying various bits of software
I was also tweeting about my progress because while trying things on my old banging machine
I actually started running with Kdenlive on the admin machine. Just as a sort of run to experiments at the same time
It allowed me to start trying different distros on one machine while I could also make [a] start on the edit
Which is probably why I ended [up] with Kdenlive because I got a bit more familiar with it
But I did get a tweet from somebody saying try pitivi which again looked really promising
[it] looked a bit like Kdenlive
But a little bit clearer on what we've going on with the audio and when I ran clips as it was really promising
Fantastic the moment I put anything on the timeline though. It locks up so that the timeline looks like it works, you can
Trim the tracks move them around
But I can't see anything and can't play anything on the timeline [so] [I] did get a little bit
Disappointed with this. I mean it appears to do what I wanted to do
But nothing really seems to work
Playing doesn't work
The other thing someone suggests. He was using blender now. I've experimented with Blender for graphics 3D graphics for [computerphile]
Haven't yet got competent enough to to produce something for [a] film, but I can see how [powerful]
It isn't what a wonderful tool that could be and so
[I've] fired up Blender went to the video editing layout and just looked at it when I?
Don't know where to start and [of] course by this time I'm starting to use Kdenlive getting quite comfortable with it
So I will give this some more time
I believe there's some really good tutorials online
So I will check those out so opening up Kdenlive just have a look at the software itself and just to see what it was
I was trying to achieve
It looks pretty similar to avid you've got a timeline at the bottom you've got the source and record windows now
They'd [in] this case
We've just got one window
But it's tabbed you've got a what they call a clip and a project monitor, and then you media at this side here
Which is kind of where I keep my media in avid, so the timelines look pretty similar
So what did I need to [achieve] when I talked about the dynamic range of the image and I also talked about the audio?
So in avid here, you can see one single audio track
But in Kdenlive if we just make that a bit larger you'll notice
That it's a stereo track. That's what the two different waveforms within the one block means
So there was no apparent way to split that out into two separate waveforms to get my different left and right
Or channel 1 and channel 2 as I referred what that means is that those two microphones are mixed together now
Why is that a problem?
[well] [if] you let both of those go out and mix together you can have an echo effect basically if these two microphone
Are picking up the same source ie my voice in this instance?
But from slightly different distances away this microphones here that microphones over there and as a result you get a curry also
That's a directional microphone. So it's pointing over my shoulder. So in this instance
It's not so much [of] an issue, but soon was recording matt it was pointing over his shoulder at the traffic
So really do want to get rid of that audio?
That was a problem on Kdenlive because of this stereo pair what I did was I chose the effect called audio channels
Copy channels and allowed it to Copy Channel 1 to channel 2 and
That I think is where the problem lies in the clicking audio that everyone is heard on the Right-hand Channel of the free software video
Whether it's me, not knowing exactly what the settings are or a slight bug?
I'm not entirely sure but that's what you'll find is going on
I'm basically wanting to Lose Channel 2 and
Just have Channel 1
so if I were to go back to the original source media here in avid for instance and
Listen to it mixed
It's not free software because first of all you can't run itunes for any book huge amounts of traffic noise
[if] I lose channel 2 it's not free software because first of all you can't write we can hear my quite clearly
If we were to lose channel 1 just to give you the difference. This is what the top mics doing free software
You can hear him you can hear in speaking, but it's quite a way. It's not quite as nice
Unfortunately when I did what I thought would give the same result over here and Kdenlive we got this
an hour
Initially that's just a playback issue
And when you export it channel one or the left-hand channel is absolutely fine in channel two has got a few clicks on it
Unfortunately it took so long to export the file and put it together that I only really found this out
Just before I was going to go live with the video now many of you out there might think well you need to fix it
And sort it out, but I'd already spent a week on this video
And I just thought this actually reflected reality of no agendas to try and kind of get across here
This is just me trying to show what happened to me trying to do what I need to do
The other thing that I needed to do as well was sort out this differences dynamic range this picture difference
And I found some really good tools in Kdenlive for that
You've got the input and output black levels what I didn't quite like was that here
They were just arbitrary numbers
Zero to a thousand where I didn't really know what that meant
so I was changing things like the black level which you can hopefully see if I
Come out of the way and what I wanted to do was just to take that with your threshold. [we're] in avid
what you would do is you would use the color correction tool and
You would use a thing called the RGB parade
Which is this thing here and you need to get things within certain limits on that scope so Kayne Life I?
keep saying it's really good piece [of] software because I think it is it's just a
Problem with workflow and the workflow that I use didn't fit with Kdenlive
So there are lots of people out there saying I
Use [kane] live or I use blender or I use pitivi or I use whatever and it works fine
Well it might work fine on your hardware and with the things that you want to do even you want to do a massively complicated
video edit
But you haven't decided to lose one of your channels of audio that might be the only reason that that mine is not work quite
[so] well [so] hopefully that gives people out there a sense of what I think went wrong on this as far [as] the audio is
concerned I have heard clicking like that occurring when
Audio is being transcoded from 40 or converted from 48 kilohertz to forty four point one killers before so perhaps
That's what's going there. Aren't many options in the copy channels effect, so I can't be sure of that
Audio wasn't the only problem. I had though
We've came live after I'd got the edit ready, and I thought I was I was good to go
[I] then had to try and get it out of the system [and] exporting was my next big hurdle
[I] started work on the free software film on
Thursday the 6th of November I
possibly started installing software on Wednesday the 5th
[this] is a list basically of all the different export
Tests what you'll notice is lots of these have zero bytes because they failed or crashed
Some of them are only a few k which for a video file is either incomplete or hideously
Compressed and then occasionally you see one that's what I call a decent sized R
15 meg file for 30 seconds and what I'd found over the course of
experiments
And going literally through the list of options on export was that only some of them worked and only some of them work with video
So for instance I some of them would only give me audio with those wonderful clicks that we all know about
So that's just the visualizer in the movie player
[some] of them would give me what I wanted, but the quality was not very good
So again, I'll give you a close-up of this, but it's very very blocky and not good enough
[I] finally hit upon an export setting that worked and it was this one
And [this] is what you ended up with other software is that other software is designed to
unfortunately it wouldn't render at this level of
Quality or this quality in this file format
But more than about 40 seconds without crashing so 40 seconds segments were about its limit
I tried 60 seconds it crashed
So I settled on choosing 30-second segments of the film and I out put the film in [thirty-second] segments
And then I had to knit it back together again after it the original film that I've got here that I edited as a guide
I've exported as well to put up as an unlisted video alongside, so people can see the difference and
that took
slightly longer than seven or eight minutes to export from avid the entire thing these is 20 minutes for every 30 [seconds] section so a
[six-minute] film is 12 sections 20 minutes each you can do the math maths maths math
It's taken quite a few hours to just get it out of the system, really
And that's me being kind saying 20 minutes these are more than [twenty] minutes plus
I have to mark up the sections frame accurately and make sure that I get exactly the right part
and of course I'm then going to have to put it all together afterwards upload it and hopefully you guys have already seen the
results of that got a piece of software called
MKV merge what it is able to do is put files together as long as they've been encoded the same and
stitch them together [without] [really]
Encoding them, and that's really important at anything to video because every time you rien code something you a lose quality
And b. Have to wait a long time
I did cheat a little bit as well the format that comes out of this camera. Here is a format called AVc
Hd, and it's very heavily compressed and if you remember the film we did with Tom Scott on
Animated gifts you talked about the idea of size as in size of a file versus
Ability to play that file and the idea that gifts are very very large because they're dead easy to play whereas a smaller more compressed
File isn't as easy to play well it certainly comes into its own with this as well
And what it means is that heavily compressed video like AVc?
Hd that you'll be recorded in I'm being recorded in
I'm being recorded in now by that camera
Is very difficult to [playback] my old computer wouldn't even be able to playback the raw files nevermind edit them?
So what I did was I?
Transcoded them and cheated a little bit and made it into hd V which is a slightly easier to handle format
I won't go into the technical side of all that right now
You can Google it
but hopefully this is giving you a little bit of an insight as to what it's
What it's meant to to try and make one of these videos with free software?
So get out there if you've got time, and if you've got hardware, but you'll strapped for cash
download these bits of software because they're good [a] really good and people are putting time and effort into making them work and
All I would say is don't expect it to [work] out of the box like a box piece of software
Don't expect to be able to basically take you back to the shop
If it doesn't do exactly we're expecting it to but there that's the real trade-off isn't it it's free